ما ننظر إليه هنا هو حقًا
نموذجي جدًا لمحمية صحراء حتر التي
تظهر لك سياج
جبالنا وصخرة
الأفيولايت وأنظمة الوادي أدناه
[موسيقى]
أنا بريدجيت هاور أنا عالم
بيئة وأستاذ مشارك خارج
الجامعة داخل  نصف ساعة من
دبي ، نحن في
مناظر طبيعية تمامًا وهذا
يمثل الإمارات العربية المتحدة الحقيقية ، تمتد جبال الحجر
على طول الطريق من أعماق عمان
عبر الإمارات العربية المتحدة.
خطوط حادة للغاية
لأننا في بيئة قاحلة للغاية
ولا نتوقع الكثير من التنوع البيولوجي ولكن
التنوع البيولوجي الذي يعيش هنا هو
بالفعل أحد
الأشجار التي نجدها في الأجساد متكيفة بشكل خاص للغاية هي هذه
الشجرة المعينة اسمها اللاتيني هو Zizza
first Spiner  كريستي لأنه
يُعتقد أن الأشواك هنا يمكنك
رؤيتها شكلت تاج أشواك
المسيح ويمكنك فقط الاستماع
لنفسك لترى كيف  الكثير من التنوع البيولوجي
الموجود
هنا للتو هو فخنا كانت الفكرة هي
محاولة العمل على التنوع البيولوجي الذي
يستخدم هذا الموطن الصغير داخل
جبال الهجا ، لذلك منذ عام 2008
وجدنا ما يقرب من 400 نوع جديد
في العلم في الإمارات العربية المتحدة هذا هو هذا
لا تقل أهمية عن جزء من الإمارات العربية المتحدة
مثل البيئة المبنية
[موسيقى]